vi presento nudo uno slide se vorrei
ricordare oggi una giornata eccezionale
perché è un punto di vista nuovo per
pensare ad un paese ad una società
l'italia che cambia il mio contributo
parte anche da una considerazione
generale che la cultura e l'esperienza
che noi oggi vediamo ma la cultura e
quello che deve emergere e quello che la
cultura nutre e il pianeta nute nuovo
paese l'italia
quindi noi dobbiamo cambiare e quindi io
vorrei dare un esperienza personale
un'esperienza lunga molto lunga perchè
io parto dal 1920 che l'hanno del
allenato ma l'evento ritengo molto
importante è legata un numero il 17
è il 17 e l'anno il quale io ho letto le
motivazioni del premio nobel james bord
sulle strutture dell'atomo è scattato
dentro di me qualche cosa erano studenti
ignorante non bravo però è scattato
qualche cosa
la cosa che mi ha portato quindi a
indirizzarmi in un settore
all'università di studi dal pd dalla
chimica la biologia dalla biologia quel
che sono i temi di che cosa della della
vita dell'uomo e nasce sempre
progressione anche quindi l'unico il tar
è stata la scuola per me per sviluppare
in fondo che l'idea di capire che cosa
c'è dentro di noi e che cosa noi
possiamo fare per gli altri
ecco che allora non è il 17
ma avevo 22 anni e mezzo idea di far i
farmaci curare la gente ignorante non
avevo una preparazione di base ma qui
vieni sempre la scuola in questo caso
era università le persone che io ho
avuto modo di conoscere
ed è dagli studi dell'università che è
nata quello che poi nel proseguo delle
attività avventurosa perché io sono
partito da zero la mia tradizione non è
che aveva moneta ecco è dani che da noi
sta è partito anche le idee per dove
avviare in un secondo tempo la ricerca
per fare che cosa per fare dei farmaci
ecco e da lì quindi il problema che la
formazione la educazione e quello che ci
deve anche portare a identificare quali
che sono i valori veri
per quale noi siamo al mondo perché noi
viviamo per chi per noi per gli altri da
qui dalle aziende dalla fortuna ecco
dalla che è scattata l'idea 30 anni fa
aveva l'occasione anche di frequentare
degli ambienti sempre dattoli di un
livello elevato scientifico del premi
nobel e ad altre persone che in del
mondo e della genetica del neuro senso
della chimica chatel era abbastanza
usuale però ho visto ho capito un
qualche cosa che bisognava fare
concretamente non soltanto produrre
ricchezza questo produrre che è sempre
un dovere di fare profitto in dovere
sociale
ma ester nizar e qualche cosa è proprio
legata alla formazione per i giovani
prendendo esempio da un mondo più
anglosassone meritano una parte della
mia fortuna ridare la società quello che
ti ha dato è quello di costruire qualche
cosa per i giovani quindi la fondazione
che porta il mio nome è una fondazione
non so se ha privato almeno l'unica in
italia è quello di produrre per i
giovani la formazione incominciando dai
18 anni in su
cogliendo quello che sono le esperienze
anche di carattere strumenti didattici
scuole strumenti dalla genetica e
biologia alla chimica dai nanotecnologia
vide scelta ma in fondo è sempre formare
le persone i giovani preparati per
vivere in un futuro inimmaginabile noi
abbiamo prospettarsi ecco il progetto
tuo cammino e 65 noi dobbiamo
prospettare di un modo che noi non
possiamo cambiare completamente
e allora sul piano del welfare sul piano
della produzione dice che ora qual è la
nostra responsabilità di formare con le
scuole con i docenti con le scuole a più
alto livello e di formare dei giovani in
grado di contribuire a quello che una
società cinesi e che sia voglio gara che
sarà diversa immaginare un mondo
sostenibile
ecco questo è il compito che nella
scuola e quindi avere quello di
concludere questo tipo di formazione
quindi insegnare per fare
qui alla fine è quello che noi dobbiamo
produrre qualche cosa che è un produrre
di ed immaginario per la nostra vita ma
anche produrre per gli altri quindi chi
parla di start up
io dico start up ricominciamo fa resta
stato a 10 anni a 15 anni perché già i
giovani sono creativi
noi dobbiamo sopportare questo il ruolo
della scuola oggi il ruolo delle
istituzioni oggi lo stato dà la
possibilità di rovesciare il modo di
aiutare quello che è in fondo una base
formidabile molto larghe theatre ma che
dando un certo sostegno
riuscirà a se stesso a cambiare se
stesso quindi questo è il nostro compito
la mia testimonianza del passato e anche
e mi augurio di un futuro migliore per
tutti noi per tutti voi grazie